.
CNN'S DREW GRIFFIN HAS THE
EXCLUSIVE REPORT.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE THE SIZE
OF A LEGO, COME IN COLORS OF THE
RAINBOW, AND IN SECONDS CAN TURN
AMERICA'S MOST POPULAR HANDGUN
FROM FIRING LIKE THIS -- TO
THIS.
>> WHOA!
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE GUN
RANGE OF THE BUREAU OF ALCOHOL,
TOBACCO, FIREARMS AND
EXPLOSIVES.
WHERE AN UNDERCOVER AGENT SHOWS
HOW A TINY DEVICE CALLED AN AUTO
SEAR CAN TURN ALMOST ANY GUN
INTO A MACHINE GUN.
>> HOLY MOLY.
>> Reporter: THIS IS HOUSTON,
WHERE A TEAM OF POLICE OFFICERS
TRIED TO SERVE A WARRANT, BODY
CAMERAS ON.
>> STEP OUT, HOUSTON POLICE.
>> Reporter: 30 YEARS EXPERIENCE
CONDUCTING 2500 PREVIOUS MAJOR
OFFENDER ARRESTS COULDN'T HELP A
COP NAMED BILL JEFFREY.
HOUSTON POLICE, LET'S DO THIS
THE --
>> YOUR FATHER DIDN'T STAND A
CHANCE.
>> NO.
HE WAS COMPLETELY BLIND SIDED,
AND THERE IS NOTHING THAT ANY OF
THEM COULD HAVE DONE TO CHANGE
THE OUTCOME.
EVERYTHING WAS DONE THE WAY IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO.
BUT THIS GUY AMBUSHED THEM.
>> Reporter: WHAT THE OFFICERS
COULDN'T SEE WAS THE
MULTICONVICTED FELON HIDING IN A
DARK APARTMENT, HOLDING A PISTOL
THAT WAS TURNED INTO A WHAP OF
WAR.
IN SECONDS, HE FIRED 30 ROUNDS,
OFFICER JEFFREY DIED, A POLICE
SERGEANT ALSO HIT, CRAWLED FOR
SAFETY AND SURVIVED.
>> SARGE, YOU GOOD?
>> I'M HIT.
I'M HIT.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION WHEN
YOU FOUND OUT WHAT THIS CRIMINAL
HAD IN HIS HANDS?
>> DISGUST, DISBELIEF, ANGER.
WE DO NOT LIVE IN A WAR ZONE.
THERE IS NO NEED FOR US TO HAVE
THESE AUTOMATIC WEAPONS ON THE
STREETS OF HOUSTON, ANYWHERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Reporter: BUT THERE IS
DEMAND.
CHEAP ILLEGAL PIECES FIRST
IMPORTED FROM CHINA WERE BEING
SOLD EASILY OVER THE INTERNET,
WHEN ATF AND CUSTOMS CRACKED
DOWN, SMUGGLING BEGAN ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
NOW THANKS TO CHEAP 3-D PRINTERS
LIKE THIS AND HOW TO
DEMONSTRATIONS ON YOUTUBE,
MAKING MACHINE GUNS IS A SIMPLE
DO IT YOURSELF PROJECT, SAYS
EARL GRIFFITH OF ATF.
>> I'M NOT COMPUTER SAVVY.
ONE OF THE GUYS SAYS IT IS EASY,
WATCH THIS YOUTUBE.
WATCH YOUTUBE AND IN A MATTER OF
15 MINUTES I WAS ABLE TO DO IT
MYSELF THE FIRST TIME.
>> Reporter: HE'S NOT KIDDING.
WE SEARCHED YOUTUBE AND FOUND
THIS.
A HOW TO DEMONSTRATION.
>> ONCE YOU GET IT 3-D PRINTED.
>> Reporter: THAT WAS STILL UP
ON YOUTUBE'S PLATFORM.
>> THAT'S HOW YOU INSTALL AND
REMOVE A GLOCK AUTO SEAR.
>> Reporter: AND GETTING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF VIEWS
EVEN THOUGH BADDIA BING BADDIA
BOOM AS HE SAYS THE GUY WAS
ARRESTED BY ATF MONTHS EARLIER,
CHARGED WITH POSSESSING, MAKING
AND TRANSFERRING MACHINE GUNS.
HE'S PLEADED NOT GUILTY, YOUTUBE
TOOK THE VIDEOS DOWN RIGHT AFTER
WE ASKED ABOUT THEM.
CALL THEM AUTO SEARS, SWITCHES,
WHATEVER, THEY ARE EVERYWHERE
AND SPREADING.
THE ATF SEES 1500 MACHINE GUN
CONVERSION DEVICES LAST YEAR.
THAT'S FIVE TIMES AS MANY AS THE
YEAR BEFORE.
GRIFFITH SAYS POLICE DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
CONFISCATED MODIFIED MACHINE
GUNS, BUT MANY DON'T EVEN KNOW
IT.
>> A LOT OF THEM HAVE NEVER SEEN
SOME OF THESE DEVICES, LIKE
LAYING HERE.
>> Reporter: RIGHT.
>> AND WHEN WE TELL THEM ABOUT
IT, THEY GO BACK INTO THEIR
EVIDENCE VAULT AND THEY LOOK AND
CHECK AND THEY FIND THIS STUFF.
>> Reporter: MORE AND MORE, THIS
STUFF IS BEING FOUND IN THE
SLAUGHTER IT LEAVES IN ITS WAKE.
THIS JANUARY, THREE MORE HOUSTON
OFFICERS WERE FIRED UPON, ALL
THREE WOUNDED, WHEN A CAREER
CRIMINAL OPENED FIRE WITH A
MACHINE GUN-STYLE PISTOL.
WHEN THEY ARRESTED HIM --
>> HANDS STRAIGHT UP!
>> Reporter: -- THEY FOUND MORE
MACHINE GUN PARTS AND 3-D
PRINTERS.
IN SACRAMENTO, A MASSACRE ON THE
CITY'S DOWNTOWN STREETS, SIX
DEAD, A DOZEN INJURED, ONE OF
THE GUNS IN THE SHOOTOUT
ACCORDING TO POLICE HAD AN AUTO
SEAR OR SWITCH TO MAKE IT FULLY
AUTOMATICIC.
>> ALL OF THESE IN THE LAST 24
HOURS --
>> NINE ROUNDS, TEN ROUNDS, 18
ROUNDS, 27 ROUNDS.
>> THAT'S LIKE TUESDAY.
TUESDAY IN AMERICA WE'RE HAVING
THIS?
>> YOU SHOULD COME HERE ON THE
WEEKEND.
>> Reporter: THIS IS
SHOTSPOTTER, IT LOCATES GUNFIRE
FOR POLICE BY LISTENING TO A
NETWORK OF MICROPHONES ACROSS
AMERICAN CITIES AND MORE AND
MORE OF THOSE MICROPHONES ARE
PICKING UP AUTOMATIC FIRE.
>> THE RATE OF FIRE, THE NUMBER
OF ROUNDS BEING FIRED IN ONLY A
FEW SECONDS IS VERY SERIOUS.
INNOCENT BYSTANDERS ARE BEING
HIT BY ROUNDS THAT WEREN'T
INTENDED FOR THEM.
>> Reporter: SINCE 2019, THE
INCIDENTS OF AUTOMATIC GUNFIRE
PICKED UP BY SHOTSPOTTER HAVE
INCREASED FROM ROUGHLY 400 TO
5600 JUST LAST YEAR.
JUST SPEND A FEW MOMENTS AT
KALIN PARKER'S MONITORING
STATION AND YOU CAN HEAR THE
HAVOC.
>> ALL OF THESE ONES I'M SHOWING
YOU HERE ARE FULL AUTOMATIC
INCIDENTS STARTING FROM THE
LEAST OF THREE ROUNDS GOING ALL
THE WAY UP TO 30 ROUNDS.
>> IN BALTIMORE, MARYLAND.
>> Reporter: THIS WAS SOME TIME
TUESDAY OR WEDNESDAY?
>> YES, SIR, 4:00 P.M.
YESTERDAY.
>> Reporter: WHEN YOU SIT HERE
AND LISTEN TO THIS AND REALIZE
WHAT IS GOING ON ON THE STREETS,
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
>> YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT UNTIL
YOU HEAR IT.
AND IT IS JUST SAD.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH A LOT OF
THESE SHOOTINGS THERE WAS A
VICTIM BEHIND THESE.
>> Reporter: IN FACT, THOSE
SOUNDS YOU HEARD FROM BALTIMORE
WERE BULLETS HITTING TWO PEOPLE
INCLUDING A 14-YEAR-OLD BOY.
BACK IN TEXAS, LACY JEFFREY IS
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING IN HER
FATHER'S MEMORY.
>> WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GET
LAWMAKERS TO LOOK INTO THIS AND
JUST CHANGE TEN WORDS TO MAKE IT
TO WHERE THESE SWITCHES FALL
UNDER A FELONY OFFENSE.
>> Reporter: SHE WANTS TEXAS TO
TREAT POSSESSION OF THESE
MODIFIED WEAPONS LIKE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES, AS A
FELONY.
>> WHAT'S THE RECEPTION BEEN?
>> NOTHING.
>> Reporter: SHE HASN'T HEARD
BACK FROM A SINGLE LAWMAKER.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> I THINK THAT, ESPECIALLY IN
TEXAS, WITH THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, PEOPLE ARE SCARED TO
TOUCH UPON IT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
ISN'T IMPORTANT ENOUGH.
WE HAVE LOST SO MANY OFFICERS,
SO MANY CIVILIANS ARE EVEN BEING
CAUGHT IN THE CROSS FIRE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE TO BE
AFFECTED BY THESE BEFORE YOU
REALIZE THAT A CHANGE NEEDS TO
HAPPEN?
>> Reporter: BRIANNA AND JOHN,
THE AUTOPSY ON HER DAD, OFFICER
BILL JEFFREY, SHOWED HE WAS HIT
MORE THAN A DOZEN TIMES IN JUST
THOSE SECONDS IN THAT DOORWAY.
WHEN SHE ASKS WHO IN AMERICA
NEEDS A GUN THAT CAN DO TH